vous êtes sur france 24 vous avez raison
bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir l'explosif
rapport zones d'eau a été remis au
président sud-africain quatre ans
banquette 5000 pages autour du doute
détournement de fonds d'au moins 30
milliards siphonner aux entreprises
publiques zoom à la nc mais aussi
l'actuel président tout le monde est
éclaboussé les détails à suivre
bientôt la première usine de vaccins à
arn messagers d'afrique luanda sera le
premier des pays à accueillir l'unité
qui devrait être opérationnelle d'ici
deux ans et fabriquer des traitements
contre le commises mais aussi contre
d'autres maladies
notre invité de ce soir a fait de la
dualité and art de vivre un artiste
marocain d'exception aussi bon écrivain
que plasticien mahi binebine était notre
invité de soirée il est venu nous
présenter son dernier livre mon frère
fantôme où il est justement question de
bus alité extrait de notre entretien à
suivre
quatre enquêtes sur la plus vaste
corruption d'état jamais mis au jour en
afrique du sud le rapport rondeau a été
remis au président ramaphosa 5000 pages
sur le siphonage méthodique de près de
30 milliards d'argent public et l'ancien
président jacob zuma n'est pas le seul
impliqué le parti nc est pointée du
doigt avec celui qui en était alors le
vice président cyril ramaphosa actuel
président sud africain la correspondance
à johannesbourg de caroline dumay
quand ils examinent les 5000 pages du
rapport rondeau les sud africains ont en
fait plus de questions que de réponses
si on regarde par exemple la
recommandation du juge qui est de se
faire rembourser l'argent qui a été
détourné les sud africains se demande
comment les banques ont pu laisser
passer ça on a des évasions de capitaux
énormes en direction de dubaï la
deuxième recommandation ce sont sur les
poursuites judiciaires et là encore
pourquoi n'y at il pas plus de
responsables politiques derrière les
barreaux un seul exemple dans la société
pgh rasage 70 locomotives ont été
achetés pour 3 milliards de rands on se
demande comment l'ins les instances de
la nc du parti au pouvoir ont pu laisser
passer ça et il se marre à cholet qui
est l'un des rares responsables
politiques à avoir été inculpé pour
corruption a plusieurs fois expliqué que
jacob zuma qu'il continue à soutenir
n'était pas seul au pouvoir à l'époque
c'est vrai cyril ramaphosa l'actuel
président était alors vice président son
silence est assourdissant
et certains pensent que ce rapport de la
commission zones d'eau va éclabousser
l'actuel chef de l'état
la première usine de vaccins arn
messagers d'afrique sortira de terre
sous peu au rwanda l'objectif est de
fabriquer d'ici 2024 des traitements
contre le coc u19 et d'autres maladies à
destination du million d'habitants du
continent cette usine sera la première
de trois prévus sur le continent
africain notamment au sénégal et en
afrique du sud sur l'itie
ces coups de pelle marque un tournant
dans la vie de nombreux africains un
site de production de vaccins sera
installé sur cette colline de kigali la
première usine de vaccins arn messagers
du continent c'est le laboratoire
allemand biotech qui on voit ce qu'il
appelle des billons teneur des
laboratoires fourni en kit et qui
devrait à terme produire 50 millions de
vaccins par an ce vaccin il ne sera pas
seulement contre lakovic 19 il sera
également contre toutes ces maladies qui
existe à l'état endémique dans le
continent africain que ce soit la
tuberculose que ce soit le matelas
malaria le paludisme donc je crois que
c'est un acte fort
l'épidémie de covina montrez-le
isolement de l'afrique en ce qui
concerne les vaccins importés d'asie
d'europe ou des états unis il existe une
usine de vaccin contre le coc vide en
afrique du sud mais pas un arn messagers
biotech en installera deux autres en
afrique du sud et au sénégal ce sont des
chercheurs et professionnels de santé
locaux qui dirigeront ce site à terme
ils travailleront avec des universités
des formateurs ainsi qu'avec des
sociétés privées qu'on biotech qui nous
apporteront des solutions pour former du
personnel par différents parcours des
formations courtes jusqu'à le diplôme
universitaire et grise
seuls 17% des africains sont vaccinés
contre le coc vide en partie à cause
d'un manque de vaccins un problème que
l'entreprise pourrait atténuer
l on passe reste de l'actualité en bref
et en images un nouveau drame
migratoires aux portes de l'union
européenne au maroc cinq migrants
d'origine africaine sont morts dans une
bousculade alors qu'ils tentaient
d'entrer dans l'enclavé espagnole de
melilla ils étaient 2000 à avoir tenté
leur chance pour ans
le président tunisien est la cible de
menaces sérieuses ce sont les
informations révélées par le ministère
de l'intérieur vous le savez le pays
traverse une grave crise politique
depuis que cai saeed s'est arrogé les
pleins pouvoirs et de son côté après
avoir refusé de prendre part au dialogue
national initié par le chef de l'état la
puissante centrale syndicale gtt rédige
désormais son propre texte avec l'appui
de la société civile elle compte
proposer une nouvelle constitution
il n'y aura pas de meeting de
l'opposition au togo le gouvernement l'a
une nouvelle fois alter vie après pour
des raisons sécuritaires et sanitaires
prévue initialement ce samedi à lomé
l'opposition avait prévu de manifester
contre la vie chère la mauvaise
gouvernance et l'impunité
au gabon la viande de volaille vivante
est interdit d'importation jusqu'à
nouvel ordre d'une décision des
autorités prise après la détection de
foyer du virus h5n1 près de libreville
une grippe aviaire qui affecte la
filière avicole qui se remet à peine de
deux longues années de crise sanitaire
liée aux copies 19 le reportage de nos
correspondants à libreville
dans ce poulailler dans village situé à
une vingtaine de kilomètres de
libreville 4 mille poules pondeuses
surveiller quasiment 24 heures sur 24
par le propriétaire de cet élevage
la crainte de ces éleveurs de volailles
la grippe aviaire qui a fait son retour
au gabon après avoir souffert des
mesures de confinement antico vide et de
la hausse du prix de l'alimentation des
volailles une grippe redouter car elle
pourrait très vite dessiné de nombreuses
élevage
ce n'est pas le monsieur qui fait mal -
faudrait que l'épidémie soit sincèrement
éradique effectué non seulement ça ça
fait beaucoup moins que nous et puis des
aliments a triplé parce qu'on fait de la
survie aujourd'hui on joue avec les
réserves ça ne se ressent pas mais dans
le mois et on verra le résultat beaucoup
fermeront ça c'est sûr
quelques kilomètres plus loin dans ce
marché les ventes de volailles se sont
effondrées depuis l' alerte donnée par
les autorités au grand désespoir des
revendeurs de plaies comme judicaël pas
mal à créer une autre c'est sûr
journalière est évalué à 40 francs cfa
mais après la mesure les recettes ont
baissé en ligne un bilan ça s'évalue à
dix mille francs cfa la journée parfois
c'est me font suite à la journée et
c'est compliqué
pour les autorités il faut aussi
construire au plus vite les foyers de
grippe identifier d'où la mesure
d'interdiction des entrées ou de sortie
des volailles dans la capitale
[Musique]
au ministère de l'élevage une cellule
gère la crise en temps réel objectif
faire appliquer au plus vite les
dernières mesures gouvernementales
notamment un contrôle accru des élevages
non si les volailles vont au marché il
faudrait que ces éleveurs nous
présentent un certificat sanitaire
vétérinaire la liesse générale l'élevage
s'assure que cet élevage est indemne
mais grippe aviaire la deuxième mes yeux
c'est la circulation dans le grand les
vraies villes les volailles vivantes
somme la zone mer qui est contaminée
sur autour de la grippe aviaire a
provoqué 17 mille cas de mortalité dont
quatre ferme située à une cinquantaine
de kilomètres de libreville le gabon qui
a interdit jusqu'à nouvel ordre
l'importation de tout volaille
notre invité de ce soir c'était mail
binebine artistes marocains iconoclaste
né au maroc vécu à paris à new york et
ne peut se faire laisser enfermer dans
une case car sa créativité n'a aucune
limite l'unique artiste africain dont
les oeuvres sont dans la collection
permanente guggenheim à new york
peintre mais aussi écrivain son talent
n'a d'égal que sa générosité dont il
fait preuve dans ces centres ils
accueillent gratuitement des enfants
défavorisés dans le partout au maroc et
il est venu nous présenter son dernier
livre mon frère en tome publié chez
stock extrait de notre entretien
alors c'est une commande finalement au
départ ça a été une commande d'un
éditeur américain qui a une collection
qui s'appelle les villes noir et il
demande à ses auteurs et à paris noir
new york noir londres noah et il a fait
à marrakech noir il demande à ses
auteurs de raconter un polar eau et en
même temps raconté la ville et j'ai
relevé le défi en quinze pages mais
j'étais frustré puisque je suis pas
nouvelliste j'ai fait le livre est sorti
le marrakech chinois mais j'étais
vraiment frustré j'avais envie de
m'étendre de la envie de couper les
personnages avaient envie vraiment de de
faire ce que je sais faire de mieux
absolue dire parler des psychologies
camper des personnages etc et j'en ai
fait un roman j'en ai parlé à mon
éditrice qui a qui a aimé l'idée et qui
m'a un peu poussé c'est parti elle est
aussi à la tête de centre dédié
justement autour de l'art pour ses
enfants défavorisés et vous en avez vous
aviez 5 il ya un sixième déjà 6e en 2003
il ya eu des attentats 14 jeunes sont
sortis d'un bidonville et on fait un
carnage à gaza donc j'ai écrit un roman
qui s'appelle les étoiles de sidi moumen
chez flammarion et un ami nabil ayouch
qui était un très bon cinéaste franco
marocain on a fait un film s'appelle
écheveau de dieu et on a gagné tellement
d'argent à gagner
on s'est dit on va rendre un peu
à ces gens et on a ouvert un premier
centre culturel dans le bidonville à 6
10 moan et on a eu soudain mille
inscrits en si peu de temps et on
pouvait plus s'arrêter là on a ouvert un
autre à tanger est notre affaire et un
quatrième à agadir et les plus beaux
évidemment ça ne pouvait être qu'à
marrakech ya
retrouvé
l'extrait et en entier d'ailleurs cette
interview sur nos sites internet sur
france 24 sur les plates formes et sur
les réseaux sociaux mahi binebine mon
frère fantôme chez stock c'est
absolument délicieux ne précipitez vous
et alors c'est ainsi que nous refermons
selon mme anne l'afrique merci à tous
ceux qui nous ont suivis de marrakech
fait en passant par casablanca
restez avec nous car l'actualité
continue sur france 24
[Musique]